if you did your homework you are not
watching vh1 what you are watching is
how we choose the next leader of the
free world
from a Spanish speaking contest that's
the twist you are authorized in
acceptable to verbal smackdowns the
democratic debates this year have been
really entertaining and that's exactly
what's wrong with them do I enjoy
watching Tim Ryan get dunked on for two
hours straight
absolutely but a candidates tendency to
dunk or get dunked on doesn't really say
much about how effective they'd be as a
leader the purpose of these debates
isn't to inform voters it's to crown a
winner and be as entertaining as
possible for NBC's June debate they
broke their debate viewership records
with 18 million viewers their second
highest rated show that week America's
Got Talent
only had 10 million viewers MSNBC
charged $100,000 per 30-second ad during
the debate and CNN reportedly required
$300,000 commitments for ads during
their latest debate in July to compare
ad costs during their regular primetime
programming range from 7,000 to 12,000
dollars and the money doesn't just come
from the night of the debate network's
clip the biggest moments and replay them
for days maximizing on ad revenue and
we're just talking about the early
primary debates we can expect bigger
ratings and bigger dollar signs closer
to Election Day now it's not surprising
that networks want to make more money
they aim to maximize on profits just
like any other company for example in
the face of declining ratings late-night
talk shows have transitioned from
traditional interviews to highly
formatted segments designed to produce
big shareable moments that they can clip
out for social media in an effort to
increase viewership and thus ad revenue
the debates are formatted to produce
similar clip out moments instead of
trying to find the candidate with the
best policy they're designed to see
which
it can outperform the others they do
this by phrasing the debate questions in
dubious ways candidate number one you
want to raise taxes to create a safety
net for underprivileged Americans why do
you hate in the middle class I am I
don't take the middle class what I'm
proposing is I'll tell you why he hates
the middle class it's because he does
not value the Americans excuse me excuse
me I don't hate the middle class but you
know what I do hate your stupid time you
look like a substitute teacher okay you
look like you have no respect for
yourself and your well being
the questions are designed to either
upset a candidate or force them into a
corner where the only escape is
attacking another candidate let's look
at a moment from the first night of
CNN's Democratic debates you support
Medicare for all which would eventually
take private health insurance away for
more than 150 million Americans in
exchange for government sponsored health
care for everyone okay take is the key
word here instead of saying that
Medicare for all would replace people's
insurance moderator Jake Tapper frames
the question as a Republican talking
point that senators Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren wants to take health
care away
this causes john delaney to fall for the
trap why do we got to be the party of
taking something away oh you know what
is the country they're running on
telling half the country that your
health insurance is illegal it says it
right in the bill and of course it let's
of one of the biggest moments of the
night Jake your question is a Republican
talking point the health care industry
will be advertising tonight on this
program Hank you senator senator Warren
it's your turn
oh can i complete
[Applause]
could I put that talking point by
choosing his words carefully
tapper was able to craft a situation in
which the candidates were riled up this
is exactly what happens on reality TV
show's producers manipulate their
subjects to stir up drama that otherwise
wouldn't have happened
for example Real Housewives is
particularly famous for its shouting
matches a producer on the show told
Business Insider that they'd manipulate
where the participants sat for dinner
scenes to optimize on the potential
drama another reality show Dance Moms
also features scenes that were set up by
producers a former participant told USA
Today that the producers set it up to
make us all yell at each other
similarly networks that host debates are
trying to stir up drama between the
candidates while that makes for good TV
it's a terrible way for viewers to
understand the nuances of a candidates
platform instead of learning anything of
value viewers are often treated to a
shouting match one that was forced into
existence debate questions are asked in
bad faith the moderators know the
questions aren't fair but their purpose
is to agitate the candidates are you
saying that senator Sanders is too
extreme to be President Trump so again I
I think if we're going to force
Americans to make these radical changes
they're not going to go along you throw
your hands up but you haven't interested
Tapper then moves on to Warren with the
same sentiment this time it didn't work
senator Warren you make it a point to
say that you're a capitalist is that
your way of convincing voters that you
might be a safer choice than senator
Sanders it is my way of talking about I
know how to fight and I know how to win
Jake Tapper isn't just the moderator
he's a journalist and a politics junkie
who knows that Sanders and Warren have
many of the same stances
and yet instead of trying to find those
minor differences he tries to pit them
against each other to create drama the
worst part about all of this is that
we've been down this road before
is there anyone on stage and can
actually hand who is unwilling tonight
to pledge your support to the eventual
nominee of the Republican Party mr.
Trump
[Applause]
mr. Trump in 2016 Donald Trump
steamrolled through every Republican
candidate mortally wounding them with a
barrage of insults and braggadocio he
never had a chance now he's doing better
he's got probably a four or five percent
chance Trump is literally a reality star
and we saw this play out during the
debates
first of all Rand Paul shouldn't even be
on this stage he's number 11 he's got 1%
in the polls and how he got up here
there's far too many people I think
really there's a sophomoric quality that
is entertaining about mr. Trump I think
his response his visceral response to
attack people on their appearance short
tall fat ugly my goodness that happened
in junior high I never attacked him on
his look and believe me there's plenty
of subject matter right there the 2016
GOP debates were centered on Trump's
zingers and attacks more and more
viewers meant more and more debates 12
in total which raked in millions of
viewers and tons of ad revenue aside
from resonating with his extremist
policies primary voters confused Trump's
performance for presidential eligibility
using the debates as a vehicle Trump
entertained his voters all the way to
the White House
any debate system where someone can rise
to the top simply by being good on
camera should be reimagined from the
ground up